that's not the plan
what's good man welcome I gotta admit
something to you guys I didn't realize
you guys were like a group I just
thought you were black Odyssey it's kind
of like an atmosphere type thing yeah
bro like they're Slug and ant and
there's so black Odyssey is a
yeah it's a Duo it's a Tucson yeah
I heard they call you guys the gruesome
twosome why I've never heard that in my
life
so how long has black Odyssey been a
thing
it's 2015. so 2015 you guys did you guys
meet in Austin yeah yeah yeah
um started as a rock band together I was
working in the village he was working in
a piece of shop nice and I was going in
there getting which pizza spot was it
was it like on six somewhere nah it was
kind of out like in the bushy part of
Austin like you guys would you consider
yourself I know you guys aren't from
Austin you're from Florida you're from
Jersey yeah yeah but you guys have been
there for almost a decade right you guys
have probably seen the like crazy growth
facts 2015 was like Peak good sales by
year Well towards the end of the great
the Great South by yours but
um is is it kind of crazy to see the
growth of tech like Austin is wild like
I just think like where fader Ford is
there's like a Whole Foods and a Target
now
like it's kind of wild like what do you
how do you guys feel about like seeing
that growth in in a city that you know
you guys call home because it is like
especially during the pandemic I feel
like everybody moved there
only [__] to me has been interesting
because we've seen like the economic
development in the city blow up crazy
but as for musicians the the
infrastructure for industry there has
been stagnant the whole time through so
it's been interesting to see it grow
side by side and how much like the music
industry has got pushed out of Austin
since you know the economic development
went crazy
um so that has just been a super
interesting perspective in general
because we think like Austin's like a
live city or a live music city right
right right right but now it's like
comedies there there's all this Tech
[__] going on like no yeah rent's
probably going up huh
is it yeah how many times have you guys
ate uh barbecue in an alley off of a
trash pail
I don't [__] with that salty ass [__]
Bros really you don't like barbecue
I liked it the first year I moved there
I feel like I've been in an alley eating
off of a trash can lid like 17 times and
I don't even live there is I'll gained
like 30 pounds when I moved to Texas I
used to be fit
well you're not like fat yeah I'm
getting there though me and you are both
getting there
I like the jacket it hides the getting
there I wear xlos now so break down your
guys's roles when it comes to Black
Odyssey
um so I approached Alejandro
um who's a guitar player yeah yeah like
I mentioned we started as a rock band
and that was the name
was the name black Odyssey when you guys
were in the band or you didn't have a
name okay I was going by Sam Houston at
the time okay it's [__] up but I was
going by Sam Houston with the band
behind you yeah okay
um so um I had these tracks I'm a
producer and a songwriter but it lacked
in live um instrumentation
so um I was trying to type in with some
people in town that that could bring
that element
and um his his the way he plays guitar
adds a different live um element to the
records that goes further than just
guitar playing
um it's almost like using your
instrument to you know achieve different
production things that you can't really
do in the box so right yeah
yeah you shred
but like Soulful shred Soulful Shredder
and just like like you said atmospheric
and like kind of making the guitar just
like a Production Tool right and that's
definitely evolved as we've evolved you
know you guys have like had some big
Legends on records like George Clinton
Bootsy Collins obviously that's pretty
crazy
how do you end up making something like
that happen
man the commonality between our hearts
because we came from two totally
different worlds I'm from Plainfield New
Jersey right that's what um Parliament
Funkadelic started okay
um and he came from Like a Rock
background so I didn't know anything
about Rage Against the Machine or I
thought Led Zeppelin was one person type
[__] like [__] shout out to Black
Odyssey
so like yeah man like I learned about
that you know world of music and in turn
I was showing him D'Angelo and I was
showing him all that kind of [__] so
um
we always had a common appreciation for
like Funk and like psychedelic music and
that was George Clinton and and Bootsy
Collins
do you get like kids no cousin who knows
him or like how do you get like I feel
like those are the easiest guys to get a
hold of yo that ass we were on we were
we were here on a trip this is George
Clinton right and um
I seen a we have been like talking to
our label and our team for a while about
trying to type in with him
um and everybody was like bro it's
[__] George Clinton like you can't
just call him right so how it works
right thanks so uh I seen a video of him
here for uh Red Hot Chili Peppers
and I showed him and I was like yo let's
go down there and just go cold up and
tell him and talk and we laughed at all
because we wasn't serious
but we're shopping on Melrose that same
day
and his [__] just walked by us and it's
[__] like silver trench like yeah I
didn't even notice who it was at first
I'm like that's a funky ass outfit then
I look and he's walking behind me and
I'm like yo that's that's George Strait
just walking down Melrose bro it was
nuts like and that's what I'm saying it
has to be God you know what I'm saying
so he's walking past and I look at all
the houses and I'm like I'm not really
the kind of [__] that that's just like
wait for a celebrity to talk to him
right but I'm like I I have to do this
you feel me right
so he went into the store and was
shopping
and I just waited outside like I was
going to phone calls Captain I wasn't on
the phone I just wanted to see normal so
I was waiting on the phone and as soon
as he walked out I acted like I saw him
by mistake and then I went up to him and
I started you know talking and I he
didn't he wasn't very responsive like I
told him I was from Plainfield and I
told him like I knew some people in his
family and [__] and he just kind of was
like yeah yeah
and he just he just he yeah I told him I
wanted to work on the record with him
right
um and I didn't like I was like that
that's not how I thought that was gonna
turn out it didn't go well in your
opinion at the time no not at all it
didn't it didn't seem to do anything two
weeks later I told him who we were I
told him the name
um
and I his daughter was with him too so I
I said you know the name to his daughter
um two weeks later she DMS me on
Instagram out of nowhere
she's like yo George George is down to
do a record which I would be played him
your [__] he hears the similarities like
oh [__] that's what you're doing yeah
George is down to do a record so we sent
him the record that day hopped on
FaceTime and he's looking much cooler on
FaceTime yeah it was [__] wild my dad
used to follow him back in the 70s so I
told him all that
and
yeah it was nuts bro your dad would go
to like shows and [__] yeah he would
just follow them on the road with my mom
really yeah your parents must have been
raging high as [__] doing all the good
drugs all of them bro all of them it was
nuts peyote shroom peyote it peyote is
like uh you know it's like a
to I think it's a cactus right yeah
that's crazy you eat it and you trip
balls oh [__] yeah that's what they I
feel like that's what they used to do
peyote yeah the Mothership Connection
it's a Mothership Connection
um what about Bootsy Collins
um we just we DM George and we were like
yo do you know Bootsy or I mean do you
know his number or can you connect me I
can connect you for sure no no I'm
saying like is that what you actually
like hey thanks for doing the song by
the way can you connect us with Bootsy
literally yeah I was like yo can you
connect me with Boosie
um he was like yeah got you just give me
a few days
he he did a DM connection and
um shout out George bro huge I'm telling
you like this is so much love
so he connected us
and hit us right he hit his back right
away relatively and he was like yeah I'm
down
I think six months went by between
responses and we had pretty much figured
like that he wasn't gonna do it right
um do it meaning narrate the whole
record and [__] like that
um and as we were wrapping up the record
we had already typed in with Keisha punk
from Griselda okay to to to be the
narrator of our of our concept album
um and we had figured that that Boosie
wasn't going to do it because they had
they hadn't responded in six months but
as we're getting ready to go into mixing
for the record he hits us and he's like
yo y'all still want me to do this I can
I can do it like tonight
so yeah that [__] just fell in our laps
he just sent it right back
uh are you are you buddy are you like
pretty hip to all the rap [__] cause you
guys getting Benny The Butcher on
records and like you know
man honestly I just evolved as a person
especially since moving to Austin right
you know because Panama City as you know
Southern Alabama right just uh you know
not as exposed over there but like
[__] get her guns out there yeah
absolutely bro there's some get her guns
in Austin though I think people forget
Austin's in Texas sometimes you're in
Austin you're like oh this is this
City's A vibe and then you like leave
and you're like oh there's some other
[__] going on here that's what I think
it's cool about them though like he
doesn't give a [__] we could be in a
room with Freddy usually the room with
Freddy I don't even think he really knew
who he was and you're just like what's
up right exactly yeah what do you what
do you do yeah yeah I think that's cool
is fun